[Musique]
toujours aussi bondissant à 32 ans
mais seul et c'est son choix mais aussi
un autre célèbre martiniquais stéphane
caristan vient lui donner son avis de
temps en temps le basque au 2019 demeure
son propre patron une solitude qui lui a
toujours réussi
je sais que mes meilleures mes meilleurs
chronos en compétition j'ai effet seul
voilà j'étais en compétition seul je
suis dans ma bulle je suis plus à l'aise
et puis et puis ça se passe bien donc
c'est pour ça que j'ai pas eu peur de me
lancer dans ce projet là et puis surtout
que ça avait déjà été fait et ça a
marché pour pas mal d'athlètes donc
voilà c'est une autre façon de voir les
choses notre façon d'avancer
aucun souci physique a déploré que les
feux sont au vert
reste à décrocher les fameux minima 13
secondes 35 sur le 110 m haies est plus
qu'abordable pour un coureur de son
niveau sur ce que je ressens je me sens
plus fort clairement voilà c'est
peut-être m'avancer dire ça j'ai pas
encore fait de deux chronos par
comparable à ce que j'ai pu faire
auparavant mais sur tous les aspects de
l'entraînement je me sens plus fort et
maintenant il faut que je me libyens
libérés afin de laisser le basque ou
reconstruits de 2019 faire encore mieux
que le basque ou tri enfants de 2016